amy coney barrett got sworn in and she's
locked in as a third
supreme court justice 48 years old first
time
a woman who's got kids going to school
she's got seven kids but she's the first
woman ever to have kids that are not out
of school they're going to school
and she's now part of the supreme court
justice and she got sworn in yesterday
so what are your thoughts on this
pre-election she was she's got an
incredible incredible resume
she conducted herself she couldn't have
done any better in those hearings
and i think she's going to make everyone
proud even the people that are pissed
about her getting in
adam yeah obviously initially when she
was nominated
there was a part of me that was like
that's not fair uh
what happened 35-yard line together
there we go this maybe he's on the 30th
but i'm going to go somewhere with this
but i'm going to go somewhere come with
me now okay come with me now
initially because what happened you know
under obama's um
nominee merrick garland there was a
precedent set that in
an election year you can't nominate uh
supreme court justice
i'm not getting political here i'm just
letting you know what happened in 2016.
there we go we obviously saw what
happened with uh neil gorsuch he got
um selected the supreme court and then
our friend the guy that likes to drink
beer what was his name brett kavanaugh
there's nothing wrong with beer i'd like
to have a beer oh my gosh did you
actually
make that comment yeah oh go ahead i'm
going that's why they call you
there we go give me a glass of soy milk
we'll have some fun and some beer
but here's my point with her the left or
you lefties out there
set her up to be some monster
we're going to have this conservative on
the supreme court we can't have this
happen
this is let's give it to the real reason
so then she shows up
and she gets grilled by the senate
uh the democrats and here's this lady
who's poised
diplomatic smart professional
doesn't necessarily commit to any
particular answers very difficult
they're not supposed to fair enough and
and this is sort of the problem with
the left and i was going somewhere with
this is that not everybody's a crazy
monster
you can't make a every person oh this is
going to tip the core this is every
conservative this is going to ruin this
roe versus wade the hell obamacare the
aca it's all going down
here's a person by all accounts is doing
everything the right way and
what she said yesterday was actually
extremely professional she said i'm not
going to let my own opinions
get in the way of doing my job and
that's all you need is someone on the
supreme court because
in case you people out there don't know
supreme court is for how long
for life 30 years 40 years for life baby
through bader ginsburg made it to almost
90.
so in my opinion you know it was
the the the opinion on her
was sort of a house of cards she was
built up to be this
evil doer but by all accounts giving you
complete down the middle opinion
seems very fair very neutral and let's
see
how good of it she's going to interpret
the constitution like you're supposed to
when
when obama was president he first got
elected and he started doing things the
way he wanted to do them he
was a bit arrogant in saying hey look
elections have consequences
okay the election of uh putting
the republicans in charge of the senate
that has consequences and this is one of
them
uh when obama put in uh sotomayer and
kagan these are hardcore left judges
they vote left every single time
on every single issue they it's not
about interpreting the constitution they
just want to change
the laws to fit their world view of
course they were not happy about it but
hey you know what elections have
consequences he was able to put his
judges in
had hillary been elected we would have
had three more
left judges and they would have not said
oh my god this is horrible it's it's
seven to three or
i'm sorry it's a six to three uh
or 72 or whatever they would have been
fine with that
republicans would have been pissed
whether they would have behaved like
children
i don't think so i mean you look at
maisie hirono when she's interviewing
amy coney barrett in these hearings i
mean these are these are high-level
hearings this is the whole country's
watching this
and she's asking amy coney barrett have
you ever been has it ever been
have you ever been accused of sexual
harassment have you ever have you ever
you know
it's ridiculous it's like when did you
stop beating your wife question it's
ridiculous i mean ask questions that
matter this is i mean
obviously this woman had no skeletons in
her closet i mean
did maisie hirono expect her to say yeah
i've been accused of sexual harassment
numerous times and
come on it's just ridiculous i have a
feeling that you're going to like this
lady but what are your thoughts
so here's here's what i would say about
amy coney barrett this is what i would
say
okay so the the part people have to
realize is
forget about trump getting elected say
he doesn't say biden gets elected
say biden gets elected it's not trump
regardless of it right
this is 6-3 and if you look at the
timeline
okay look at the timeline of how long
these justices stay in
right the highest one is william douglas
he stayed in for 13 358 days
each year has 365 days if you do 365
times 10 it's what
no it's 33 600 this is nearly
40 years these guys stayed in right
we're not talking a little bit of time
by the way
there is nearly 22 that have stayed in
more than 10 000 days that's more than
years they stayed in clarence thomas got
in october 23rd of 91
october 23rd of 91 till today what is
october 23rd of 91
that's how many years ago 29 years ago
he's still in right a matter of fact he
swore
uh swore in yesterday right they were
doing the entire thing
so if you look at the list here and you
go through
even a john paul stevens right john paul
stevens got sworn in
december 1975 you know when he left june
29 2010
75 to 2010.
75 i wasn't born yet you weren't born
yet
2010 is just 10 years ago this is a long
time for them to be put in
if if the average amount of time you
can't really do the average amount of
time but if you look at the list here
here's what you're seeing this is the
list okay how much they stayed in all
these guys are in the 10 000 club
these are the seven this is 20 years
right here if you look at anything here
is 20 years
40 of them is 20 years and we've had 115
of them there's
yeah there's certainly a a move on the
part of presidents to pick judges that
fit their ideology but also are going to
last a long time you look at sotomayor
and kagan these are young women
yes when they were put out right and
they're going to be on a long time as
well
a very long time i mean when you think
back to that that thomas hearing that
was another disgrace
um do you remember any disgrace when
when rbg was
was nominated no i don't remember
anything do you remember a disgrace
where the republicans
uh were what was what are you surprised
no because
there's well no i'm not surprised it's
just the way they behave it's just the
way
uh when the left doesn't get their way
they just here's a question
like children here's a question though
here's a question though kyle if you
want to pull up this 60 minutes
interview with
byron dudell if you want to uh put it on
he
they have it he doesn't even have it
don't worry about it if you pull up the
60 minutes with uh with uh
buy uh with byron you don't 60 minutes
would buy don't pull up the 60 minutes
we'll buy not buy
i'm not going to be able to hear this no
no okay so check this out so this is
actually a good question they asked him
so watch this here's his answer
on packing a court okay if you want to
press play
if elected what i will do is i'll put
together a national commission
listen bipartisan speed it up to 1.5
scholars
constitutional scholars democrats
republicans liberal conservatives
and i will uh ask them to over a 180
days come back to me with
recommendations as to how
this is what he's saying scholars left
and right come back to me within 180
days of recommendations have you heard
that script
i've heard it now 10 times scholars have
debated and i've looked to see what
recommendations that commission might
make so you're telling us you're going
to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court no whether there's a number of
alternatives that are go
well beyond packing this is a live ball
oh it is a light bulb oh it is a light
bulb we're going to have to do that and
you're going to we're going to have to
do that
okay as well the last thing we need to
do is turn the supreme court into just a
political football whoever has the most
votes gets whatever they want
presidents come and go supreme court
justice is stated he's right about that
100 right so pause it okay so if you
want to pause it so here's here's what i
notice
even the left and the right says
that the left didn't go after her
hardcore the way
they did against kavanaugh okay they
didn't so
their strategy no way in the world no
not like kavanaugh kavanaugh was uh
the worst ever right has she been a male
they would have descriptions this just
tells you
great choice for trump on who he picked
let's just give him credit the fact that
he chose somebody
that you're gonna have a hard time going
after somebody like this seven kids
she's adopted you know good life she's
done the right things you know so he
chose the right person
but here's a problem what happens when
somebody stays quiet for too long
if an enemy is quiet for too long what
do you think about
they got something up there there's like
something up their sleeves that's all
i'm going to tell you
meaning if they're this quiet and
they're not even bringing us up
and biden wins get ready get ready to
see what happens because everything is
you know what six three is i don't know
six three is like
it is but i understand that they're not
i mean yes the three are absolutely
going to vote the way you know they're
going to vote the six are not
guaranteed let me ask you a question out
of the six you think four are going to
go right
every single time yeah so what do you
mean so it's four three i know but it's
not six three it doesn't make it
but you need fourth to be three so you
need four to be three i got six of them
chances are out of the six
at least four of them are gonna work
that way if if you got four
and the other two vote with the three
then you got five four on the left
so so and they've done it so they've
shown that they've shown they're trying
to so they need to want to say no to do
five four they need one to say no to do
five four and understand that that
this whole thing this is a this is a cat
and mouse game rbg was
up in years rbg could have resigned
during you're making this seem a lot
looser than it is you're talking about
the conservatives has six left has
three and would anybody be complaining
if it was the other way around no i'm
not
i'm not complaining or anything what i'm
trying to tell you is this is a massive
victory it's a conservative it is but
understand there's a lot of people that
had
that had a say in this rbg had to say
and that she could have resigned
and what whatever sixth year of obama's
terms nobody's disagreeing what you're
saying if the left had it that way they
would have done a heartbeat and said the
same lines that you're giving up right
now
it kind of you know elections have
consequences all i'm saying to you is
do you really think the left is going to
sit there and not do anything about it
no they're going to play the way they
play what do you think they're going to
do about it they're going to pack the
court
you think they're going to get elected
yes they're going to pick what's the
chances of them packing the court in
your opinion
80 80 if you're watching this right now
you're following this story with amy
what do you think's the chances of the
left pack in accord what are your
thoughts if you're watching this right
now what are your thoughts
if biden gets away if biden gets elected
well they've come up with some excuse
and the excuse
the court the excuse will be some sort
of diversity play exactly
i already heard kamala here say that by
the way in in the debate with pence i
don't know if you caught that guy so
when you talk about packing the court
number one this is quite frankly a term
that i've never even heard of
until about six months ago is this
something you've heard before uh
it hasn't been done 150 years no so
people are acting like they're gonna
pack the court they're gonna pack the
car oh my god the court packing
buddy nobody's even brought this up ever
and then kamala tries to redefine what
packing the court means
in her vice presidential debate she says
well you know let's talk i want to talk
about packing the court let's talk about
packing the court
you appointed 50 justices or judges
and none of them were black come on
yeah so i mean pecking the court means
increasing the number of justices
okay so just so you know most people are
saying hundred 90
one million most people don't know so
most people saying a hundred percent a
million percent
like they don't know that that's their
opinion congrats mazel tov
that's your opinion but the volvo guy
said ten thousand percent
okay well if he said ten thousand
percent random uh
uh don't ever by the way sid childhood
says one percent they're gonna pack okay
well sid chadwell also doesn't know
what's going on in uh
well they're they're court packers and
they won't answer the question
well then luke must be right i mean
because luke said it
so if you're thinking about packing the
court what does that mean one extra
justice
justice no no no no no i mean two extra
justices
that mean five extra yes yes three to
five it seems to be highly aggressive
even to put one extra
because it's been nine for how many
years a long time but the answer to that
is 150 years
so if you add one more than nine and you
make it 10.
it's not going to make it 10. you just
let just come with me here
you put one more you haven't done that
in 150 years you put two more
they've never done that right so this is
this is some serious stuff
strategy interesting how they're trying
to shroud or not exactly say what
they're going to do because
their base wants them to pack the court
and so
if they they're afraid to say that
they're afraid to say they're going to
pack them there's
no question about it right but they're
afraid to say that why are they afraid
to say that
it may help them joe biden energized
their babies before
uh the election yeah which is one week
away by the way who has whoever's lived
under a rock
said he'd give this answer so what he's
going on now i mean a third of the
people that are correct
but i mean before tuesday so a week from
tuesday
guys make sure you get out there and
vote nobody could vote till tuesday that
would be before the election
but the elections already started people
have been voting for were you going
somewhere where you go
are you saying that the fact that 150
years we've been at nine there's no way
in the world they're gonna pack now i'm
just saying people are so convinced
everyone who's 100
100 no i don't i'm like at least byron
says i think it's 80
okay that's a high likelihood well i
think 100 chance they'll try whether
they'll get it done
i don't know the question is from a from
a campaign standpoint do you think this
is a good idea for them to say well then
to not say whether they're going to pack
the car
i i
don't want them to pack the court no way
they don't they they don't want them
independents are kind of like listen so
they're trying to couch it so they know
that their base knows they're going to
but they're
trying to fool the independent they're
not going to say it they're not going to
say so you think their their their
rhetoric now is designed to basically
sort of but it's a brilliant rhetoric
signal to their base that they're going
to
what what biden said that line biden has
said now 100 times
yeah that's obama's speaking that's not
him speaking we're going to bring
attorneys from both sides to the isle
conservatives and liberals and we're
going to sit there
when did obama ever say that no no
meaning he would biden would never say
something like that that's
word that he got on a call with obama
said what do i say when they're asking
me a question like this well here's how
you answered we said we're going to get
people from both sides in the room
and see what decision we're going to
make biden wouldn't answer like that
biden would be looking at with a deer in
headlines so
joe yeah but uh obama here but what i
what i am saying to you here's the
following
remember yesterday we're at dinner okay
the person that we talked to was the
average voter
for her age which is for her age right
she was 20
29 20 yes 29 is how old she was six one
by the way
never played that one never played or
highly disappointed or volleyball
so she's from michigan okay she went to
school
i said when did you go from fox to cnn
she said music music school
when i went to music school i smoked a
lot of pot and i hung out with people
that were you know
telling me she said she met a lot of
different types of people you know she
said
wait but all this all the same so and
then she said was it because of the weed
though but she no she joked about it i'm
just telling you what she said so she
went through all this stuff
and then if you remember he brought up
abortion okay
oh i remember that yeah he went off yeah
by the way it was
it was like all of a sudden so what do
you think about abortion the girl's like
i'm just trying to take your order here
buddy
so next you know the boss shows up and
the boss is like well i heard a
conversation guys are having because you
know
he's like this is a brand new employee
you know she just started with this two
weeks ago
we're already talking about everybody
want to know her you know what she said
here's a question byron asked it's very
important to hear what byron asked byron
asked the question said so what do you
think about abortion
and she said i believe the woman should
have the ability to choose what they
want to do with their body right
and he said okay at what point at what
point
at nine uh you know eight months three
weeks
she said if the woman wants to do it
they should have the right to do it so
they're not alive yet they're like no
they are alive they're just not born yet
well no they're not born yet
and then you went to all the way up to
what if the baby is born and then they
said we wanna
you know and then you went to the
virginia uh politician i think you were
mentioned fourth term abortion four-term
abortion is what you're talking about he
said well i don't think that's right but
if the woman's got to have the right
right
this row versus wade let me tell you
it is so scary for the left to get rid
of that
that they will do anything in their
power to make sure that never happens
and if it means court packing they're
going to do it
how long have we had roe vs
how long have we had the freedom to
choose for women when it comes down to
abortion
73 so from 73 till today what's 73 till
today nearly 50 years we've had right 47
years
for 47 years it's been accepted now
meaning they're sitting there not having
to worry about it liberals on the left
they're sitting there saying you know i
don't have to worry about
it conservatives are saying we've got to
change this but liberals are like dude
it's in law you can't do nothing about
it right it's officially
at risk now and this is a fight they're
going to have to fight for 30 years do
you really think for 30 years are gonna
be okay with six three i don't think so
i don't think so so to me when you're
asking about court packing
it isn't just about court packing it's
about roe versus wade
and roe versus weight is going to go
through them it's not
president it's not congress it's not
senate it's supreme court of justice
and these are the types of things that
you're going to see them sitting around
saying what the hell can we do
he said even biden said there are many
different things to do
there are many different things that we
could do he talked about going beyond
court packing exactly so
this is their words adam so i know you
know your you know where
you're coming from is we don't know for
a fact is that 100 is down you're right
we don't know a thousand percent what
are they gonna do
but when you're avoiding the one
question where mike pence is like is it
fair to say i think it's important for
us to know that she didn't answer the
question and kamala had the big smile on
her face
so just so everybody knows she hasn't
answered a question about court packing
and the moderator was changing it and
then kamala says what wait wait wait
wait
you want to talk about court backing
i'll talk about court packing
do you know that 120 judges none of them
are african-american
bingo you just said exactly your
strategy the strategy is
racism the strategy is going to be not
enough episodes deflect deflection no
it's not deflect
they revealed their strategy by not
answering it you're saying
no she gave the answer she gave the
answer
the diversity the diversity answer she
gave it
you